12 days of horror in ukraine as vladimir
putin carves an even larger trail of
destruction russia being accused of war
crimes after raining down artillery
shells on civilians trying to flee to
safety at least eight people including
children killed in a city outside of
kiev ukraine says russia is using
medieval-style siege tactics to punish
cities in mariopol where 200 000
civilians are struggling to escape the
city has been without water and power
for days with carnage and suffering
increasing russia has now sent nearly
100 percent of its forces staged at the
border into ukraine president zielinski
once again calling on the west for more
help
this is murder deliberate murder think
about the sense of impunity of the
invaders
they announced their planned atrocities
why because there is no reaction because
there is silence
not a word as if western leaders have
dissolved tonight the audacity of the
aggressor is a clear signal to the west
that sanctions against russia are not
enough
let's go to benjamin hall in the
ukrainian capital of kiev where it is i
think i believe it's midnight there
where you are benjamin what's the
outlook tonight
it is dana yes and at the moment it's
quiet here in keith but i can tell you
just a few hours ago there was heavy
shelling across large parts of the city
around all the outskirts to our north
our north west and our west
clearly
vladimir putin's force is making an ever
bigger push for this city look on the
one hand today we have seen a real
escalation on the attacks on civilians i
mean you see some of the pictures coming
from cities like kharkiv and mariopol
and corson it is devastating whole
district absolutely flattened leaving no
doubt whatsoever that putin is
indiscriminately now bombing these
cities hitting schools and hospitals and
then on the other hand you have
putin offering humanitarian corridors
potential peace talks but everyone here
knows those on absolute fast we talk
about the humanitarian corridors at a
mario pole yesterday where buses were
supposed to go in and rescue those 200
000 the red cross today saying that that
route out had been mined on other
attempts to get them out shells fell
around the buses making it impossible to
evacuate anyone
and then today another off of
humanitarian corridors out of six areas
they were all leading to russia and
belarus asking the very people who are
fleeing to head right into their captors
hands and so right now
the trust in vladimir putin is
incredibly low nevertheless there was a
third round of negotiations today
between the russians and the ukrainians
in belarus
there were there was no outcome
specifically they said they discussed
further humanitarian uh efforts but
nothing uh really came of it and so
right now we have this scenario where
the escalation is all on putin's side he
is hitting towns he's hitting villagers
and he's inching ever closer to villages
but the fact is the ukrainians are com
still doing remarkably well at holding
back the russians and so what the
russians have started to do is use their
longer-range weapons we've seen them use
longer-range artillery more from the air
and that is a lot less precise and
that's why we're seeing civilian
casualties rise dramatically also
reports that the stingers were being so
successful these planes that were coming
in lower to drop dumb bombs those planes
have just started flying a lot higher
that also means far less accuracy so
again it is a scorched earth uh move at
the moment the same way that we had seen
in aleppo and grozny it is really
worrying right now what we're seeing and
it is all because the ukrainians have
fought so well so bravely at holding
them back that we're seeing this rise in
indiscriminate attacks dana
benjamin thank you stay safe and i'm
sure we'll see you on the channel later
this evening
judge jeanine um
you know for those civilians who are
trying to flee to realize that the route
that they were told that they could take
was mined is
very offensive it's just heartbreaking
and offensive and yet here they are the
ukrainians go back to the table again
today imagine sitting across from the
russians and asking for additional
humanitarian corridors well look the
fact that they mine those evacuation
corridors the fact that there is
shelling in those corridors or that
those corridors lead to russia or
belarus is an indication that this guy
is not an honest actor we've been
sitting here for 12 days okay and and
talking about him you know zielinski put
it perfectly this is murder deliberate
murder with impunity with no consequence
and how is it that one man is allowed to
upend the world like this how is it that
he is able to push everyone's buttons
and basically kill indiscriminately
children with cancer
who are simply trying to get their
cancer treatments children being killed
with their families leaving i don't need
to describe it all you have to do is
turn on the television while the world
watches we're just four years in this i
you know i understand the no-fly zone
but even canada has said we're not going
to accept any oil from from russia and
now what we're doing and i don't want to
get into the the later parts of the show
but we want to work with venezuela well
didn't we hate maduro we want to work
with iran well aren't we going to fund
the nuclear bomb with iran and you know
why it's so easy to just make a left
turn a lower turn and go to texas go to
pennsylvania we can be energy
independent and the truth remember last
week dana when i said 48 percent of
americans are willing to suffer and pay
higher prices today it's 71 of americans
are willing to suffer the higher prices
in order to help these people people are
we're good people across the world and
this pig has got his thumb on in his
knee on our neck jesse how do you assess
things today
it's awful i mean this was a bad weekend
for the ukrainians for the civilians in
ukraine and i'm not shocked anymore i
think in the beginning people were
shocked by the horror that vladimir
putin was imposing on these people
you know it's shocking but we shouldn't
be shocked this guy is a barbarian it's
napoleonic what he's doing and
it's going to get worse and the american
people have to understand that because
in the beginning we thought the
sanctions were super effective and how
could we do this we've never seen
anything like that
it's going to get a lot worse before it
gets a lot better and the president has
not prepared the country for a long game
and this is a long game our american
strategy the western strategy is to turn
the russian empire
in into a graveyard in ukraine and
that's going to take a very long time
and we're going to see a lot of dead
bodies and it's going to be sad
right now it's i'm not sure in the next
couple weeks or months the american
people are going to vote the same way as
they did in that poll we're in recession
territory pretty much we're already in
correction territory we can't afford 200
oil we can't afford five dollar oil joe
biden has not said construction costs
are going up technology costs are going
up what's he done about wheat prices
what's he done about food prices
fertilizer the black sea is basically
done no one's no shipping companies
going in there no one's underwriting any
sort of trade in the entire region so
i'm afraid you're going to have a domino
effect that's going to spiral out of
control right as you come out of a
recession
this country's not going to have a
recovery if we're going to get hit in
the face with five dollar a gallon
gasoline and the american people are not
prepared for this the president has not
prepared the country for this and we are
heading
really fast to a potential
war talking about a no-fly zone people
are getting trigger-happy we're sending
in planes potentially what happens if a
a nato ally sends in a plane and that
nato plane from a nato country shoots
down a russian plane you think russia's
gonna be okay
with a polish plane shooting dead
russians at their doorstep i don't i
don't think joe biden has wrapped his
head around where we're going here
harold i agree with some of the things
jesse is said and i disagree but
slightly different point of view i i
think the elements you've laid out are
exactly right i think the president's
done a lot better job
of trying to prepare the country for the
consequences in fact even if he doesn't
we we're living the consequences we're
paying more for gasoline we're paying
more for food paying more for food i
call it the new ppp
protect
uh punish
and power back
our interests are are at risk
in ukraine democracy decency humanity
sovereignty uh you can't let this nation
cross that line particularly a nation
with the history that that the soviets
had and with the language that he's
talking we've kept together nato it's
been hard now i know that there's an
interest on some to try to score
political points with this but when
problems huge problems are in front of
you you got to solve them and if that
means bringing people together who don't
disagree who you disagree with in the
past in your own party the other party
you've got to figure out how to do it
two you got to punish putin and here's
where the question becomes how much and
how willing are we to pay is that 71 76
77
whatever the number may be how high will
that number stay and you raise this if
prices get to 10 11 12 a barrel we've
unplugged him from the world financial
system are we willing to ban the kind of
ban that people want summer proposing on
their oil and energy products perhaps
similar to what canada has done if we do
that those are some who criticize this
white house for not tackling inflation i
would dare say we've not seen inflation
if we ban oil and energy products like
we're saying and finally we got to power
back and judge this is where i agree
with you wholeheartedly that power back
we have to think about ways to restart
uh energy projects here in the country
be it keystone be it on other leases on
lands that we're not there's been some
talk in the white house about doing that
i think they need to go further and we
have to be serious and intentional about
helping the europeans the marshall plan
after this effort here is a marshall
plan to help the europeans find new
energy sources no nation should be
dependent on iran venezuela or russia
for energy sources we were able to get
off middle east oil and energy products
after 9 11. we have to make that the
legacy of this effort once we're able to
get out of this waffle episode we're in
right now sorry we're gonna have a
chance to talk about energy in the next
block do you wanna you know you had a
very interesting guest of robert gates
on your show on saturday night
anything that he said on saturday that
now you look to monday and say aha
that's what he meant oh we got to choke
this guy out now i think bob gates was
secretary of defense for republican
democrat was the cia director worked for
seven presidents i thought he was a
perfect person to say this is historic
time and i think what he was trying to
say is vladimir putin's a bad actor
nothing we will ever do will change the
way he is not much different than the
guy he dealt with uh when he came in
for president obama uh when he came in
for president bush replacing don
rumsfeld and then for president obama
and he thought it was a huge mistake
when president obama said blankets and
mres when he took uh parts of georgia so
here's the thing uh jesse as much as i
agree with the sentiment
we're not living in the world in which
we're calling the rules right now right
now we are dealing with an actor that
has no interest in dialing back and
coming back this is the moment that we
have to stand out and choke him out
where it's going to get so much worse in
two years as he takes moldova starts
moving on on the baltic nations and then
the rule 5 is not going to be a gray
area it's going to be yes or no area
here's what i found macron is also in on
another planet he came out and says
russia too must be respected as a
country there is no durable piece of
russia is not part of a great
architecture of peace in our continent
because history and geography are
stubborn he vladimir putin is the
problem he could not be brought in to
the family of nations we have tried and
he's laughed in our face he has
destroyed a country he's killing
children and he doesn't care about it he
has press conferences with flight
attendants having a great time he does
not feel this pain we have to have total
all-in sanctions convince the europeans
to get off oil and my goodness do we
stand for anything 1 800 venezuela oh
iran we'll deal with we'll let you
fulfill what we used to get from russia
and now we're going to actually uh we're
actually going to say it's only seven
percent of their output is our input on
their oil so that's why we should not
worry about stopping russia's input oil
from coming into our country of course
we should we backstop it with friendly
nations we have to stand for something
we don't have relations with maduro of
venezuela we don't recognize them how
dare we cut an oil deal with them with
iran do you know what's happening with
this iranian deal this is a travesty
what's about to happen with the iron
deal we're going to be fueling terror in
the middle east for the next 50 years
we'll come back to this yeah we have
more to come about this because
president biden is looking to offset
surging gas prices by cutting deals with
a new set of dictators we gave you a
preview we'll be right back hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else